this weekend scholars and conspiracy
theorists will continue to scour the
newly released 2,800 secret documents
about the assassination of President
Kennedy the revelations are quite
interesting even though President Trump
blocked the release of all of the
records over what he described in a memo
as quote potentially irreversible harm
to national security but late last night
mr. Trump tweeted that after consulting
with intelligence agencies he will now
release the final documents with only
the names of the living redacted Larry
Sabato is the director of the University
of Virginia Center for politics an offer
of the author of the 2013 book the
Kennedy half century he's in
Charlottesville Virginia Larry welcome
Thank You Anthony
so Larry first of all what exactly have
they given us here in these records and
and what did you find interesting
they've given us a ton of stuff good
stuff that's the final word yes a lot of
it is interesting some of its worthless
you can't even decipher the handwriting
and there's no owners manual there's
there's only the most rudimentary table
of contents but as you go through it and
we've been going through it since it was
released but I've got to tell you we're
nowhere near even a quarter of the way
through there is so much material there
but you come across little nuggets that
are fascinating no big things but a
bunch of nuggets that can fill in some
blanks maybe that have existed for a
long time or augment your view of Oswald
or other characters involved in the
assassination well everyone wants to
know of Oswald acted alone or at least
conspiracy theorists do Larry so is
there any evidence that he didn't act
alone I haven't seen it yet but there
are hints of various things there are
the FBI and the CIA checked out every
rumor and and piece of gossip they were
given every report that came in in the
weeks and months after the assassination
as you would expect and as they should
have done for example they were trying
to determine whether reports that Oswald
had
travelled with a companion down to
Mexico City were true from what I have
read so far they were never able to
determine it one way or another but it
matters you know who went with him on
that critical trip seven weeks before
the assassination when he went to the
Soviet embassy and the Cuban embassy and
by some reports said in the Cuban
embassy when he was denied a visa that
he was going to prove his fealty to the
revolution by killing President Kennedy
that's kind of important yeah and you
wonder what happened to that information
if indeed he said it so much of this
after 54 years no one's ever going to
determine whether it's true or not right
so Larry among the stuff that you've
looked at so far what else stands out to
you well while we're on the subject of
Oswald I had not seen maybe others had
come across this but I didn't realize
that
Oswald had threatened the life of
President Eisenhower - this came from a
military friend of his and it occurred
in 1957 or 1958 during Eisenhower's
second term he apparently threatened his
life because he was an oppressor of the
poor people a capitalist leader that
that is actually a theme that I've seen
throughout Oswalt life there's a violent
theme there at various times he
threatened the life of former vice
president Richard Nixon or he did he
claimed to his wife he was going to kill
Nixon during one of Nixon's trips to to
Texas during that interregnum between
his vice presidency and presidency we
know that he's shot at General Edwin
Walker and nearly killed him he missed
him by an inch in April 1963 apparently
using the same rifle that he employed on
November 22nd 1963 so this is a misfit
who had violent tendencies in some
respects he was a sociopath and that's
the testimony of people many people who
knew him in and out of the military
Larry Sabato our resident JFK gumshoe
combing through the files with a
fine-tooth comb thanks for that Larry
loads of stuff loads of stuff keep
breathing Larry
well do